[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله
معكم محمد كريشان في هذه اللحظات عواصمه
في العالم تعيش على وقع احداث هامه
البدايه من العاصمه الروسيه موسكو ومؤتمر
دولي هو الحادي عشر للامن الذي ينظمه
الجيش الروسي ويعقد بالقرب من العاصمه
بحضور اكثر من 800 ضيف من 76 دوله ليس من
بينها اي من الدول الغربيه
والى العاصمه البولنديه وارسو التي نظم
فيها اليوم اكبر عرض عسكري منذ الحرب
البارده بمشاركه الفي جندي من بولندا
وغيرها من الدول الاعضاء في حلف شمال
الاطلسي
والى العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس التي تعيش
اجواء ترقب بعد مواجهات المسلحه استمرت
ساعات
وتم تسليم قائد اللواء 444 محمود حمزه
بوفد عسكري تابعا لحكومه الوحده الوطنيه
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
مع دخول معارك السودان شهرها الخامس نائب
رئيس مجلس السياده يعلن طرحه خريطه طريق
تبدا بوقف لاطلاق النار وتدشن عمليه
سياسيه تؤسس لمرحله انتقاليه ويقول قوات
الدعم السريع انه لا مكانه لجيشين في دوله
واحده والامم المتحده تدعو لانهاء فوري
للاعمال العدائيه وسط تحذيرات من خروج
الوضع عن السيطره
ازمه النيجر بين الدبلوماسيه والتدخل
المحتمل وقبيل اجتماعا لقاده جيوش
المجموعه الخميس قال رئيس نيجيري ان اكواس
لا تسعى لتعقيد المشكله وتتفهم خوف الشعوب
من العمل العسكري بوتين يؤكد لرئيس مالي
اهميه ايجاد حل سلمي وواشد تقول انه لا
تزال هناك مساحه للدبلوماسيه والاستعاده
النظام الدستوري
تصاعد القتال على الجبهه الغربيه
لاوكرانيا القوات الروسيه تستهدف الفيف
وجوارها بعشرات من صواريخ كروس
تعلن تعزيز التحصيناتها على الحدود
الشماليه المتاخمه لبيلاروسيا وروسيا وعلى
واقع التصاعد المعارك بالقرب من حدودها
[موسيقى]
هولندا تنظم اكبر عرض عسكري منذ الحرب
البارده
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا ناقشنا معكم سياقه ساعات من
المواجهات المسلحه التي شهدتها العاصمه
طرابلس والتي وصفت بالاعنف خلال العام
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا
عليكم السؤال التالي السؤال يقول ما اسباب
تجدد التوتر الامني في العاصمه طرابلس كيف
كانت الاجابات
32% قالوا ان السبب هو تعثر التوصل الى حل
سياسي دائما للازمه في ليبيا بينما قالت
39% ان السبب يعود الى وجود اكثر من فصيل
مسلح في ليبيا فيما قال 29% ان الازمه
تكمن في تعدد الاجهزه الامنيه في البلاد
هذا سؤال سيبقى كالعاده مطروحا على
منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر حاليا
على الشاشه
لقاء على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
بعد اتهامات للترامب بالابتزاز في قضيه
انتخابات 2020 الرئيس الامريكي السابق يصف
لائحه الاتهامات بمحكمه تفتيش
في اعلان مفاجاه تتقدم الحكومه السودانيه
بخريطه طريق تقوم على وقف فوري للقتال
وتدشين حوار شامل يؤسس لمرحله انتقاليه
الاعلان عن طريق عن خريطه الطريق هذه جاءت
في خطاب لنائب رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقاليه في السودان مالك عقار
تبدا خارطه الطريق للتوصل لوقف اطلاق نار
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريه
المتمرده وتحديد مواقع تجميع قوات الدعم
السريع المتمرده بعيدا للمناطق المدنيه
للفصل بين القوات والتزام بعدم تعرض
المواطنين لخطر الاقتتال وذلك حتى تكتمل
عمليه وضع اجراءات خارطه طريق الترتيبات
الامنيه لتلك القوات ويعقوب ذلك بدايه
العمليه الانسانيه بايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه للمواطنين في المناطق المتضرره
من الحرب كما سنقوم بالتركيز ايضا على
ضمان حياه طبيعيه بقدر الامكان للمواطنين
السودانيين
وقال ملك عقار ان عمليه سياسيه شامله
ستعقب انجاز خريطه الطريق وتضم جميع القوى
السياسيه المدنيه المهتمه بتاسيس الدوله
السودانيه
ستعاقب هذه الخطوات الشروق في تصميم عمليه
سياسيه شامله تضم جميع القوى السياسيه
المدنيه الراقبه والمهتمه بتاسيس الدوله
السودانيه ويكون الهدف منها هو مخاطبه
القضايا التاسيسيه للدوله السودانيه من
اجل بناء نظام دستوري وسياسي مستقر
وابتعاد القوى السياسيه للصراع حول تشكيل
فتره الانتقال لتقاسم بقايا السلطه او
الحكم ان طريقه الانتخابات التي تقوم على
اساس الدستور وتيار الشعب السوداني
لقياداته يجب ان يكون هو الوحيد لتولي
مقاصد الحكم
ومسؤوليه البلاد
ودعا نائب رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقاليه
في السودان ملك عقار كذلك دعا قوات الدعم
السريع الى النظر بعين المسؤوليه الى
التطورات الحاسره وقال ان اسباب القتال
التي اعلنها الدعم السريع ضغط عليها سلسله
من الجرائم والانتهاكات وفق تعبيره واضاف
ان الدعم السريع يجب ان يعي انه لا وجود
لجيشين في دوله واحده
الرساله الثالثه لقوات الدعم السريع
وقياداتها
اتركوا عنكم القلوه وانظروا بعين
المسؤوليه الى ما حدث ويحدث فان دواعي
الحرب المعلنه من طرفكم من بناء دوله
الديمقراطيه ومحاربه الاسلاميين وانهاء
حكم دوله 56 كلها ضغط عليها سلسله الجرايم
والانتحاكات التي ارتكبتموها من قتل
واغتصاب وتهجير واحتلال بيوت ونحن ممتلكات
المواطنين واحتلال المؤسسات الخدميه وهذه
الجرائم جعلت بينكم وبين الشعب السوداني
قوه كبيره
مع دخول القتال في السودان الشهر الخامس
وسط ازمه انسانيه متفاقمه وتقدر الامم
المتحده عدد القتلى باكثر من ثلاثه الاف
اغلبيتهم من المدنيين كما اشارت الى ان
اكثر من سته ملايين سوداني باتوا على شفا
المجاعه
القتال لا يهدا في السودان ويدخل شهره
الخامس
توافقات لم تنجز وهدن لم تصمد والملايين
يعيشون معاناه قاسيه بحسب الامم المتحده
البدايه منتصف شهر نيسان ابريل الماضي
اشتباكات اندلعت في محيط القصر الرئاسي
ومطار الخرطوم الدولي والقياده العامه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
تطورت حده القتال وتعقدت الخريطه
الميدانيه بشكل متسارع استهدف الجيش بسلاح
الطائرات مقر الدعم السريع في انحاء
مختلفه من العاصمه
توسعت الاشتباكات تباعا قتال عنيف دار حول
مطار مدينه مروي في محاوله من الطرفين
للسيطره عليه ولايه البحر الاحمر لم تكن
بمنئا مدينه بورتسودان بمينائها استراتيجي
شهدت مناوشات محدوده عند تلك النقطه ذات
واضحا ان القتال يتمحور حول منافذ البلاد
للخارج كمطارات الابيض والفاشر والجنينه
دائره النار استمرت في التمدد الى كردفان
ودرفور وعادت الام الحرب الطويله التي
عصفت بالمدنيين هناك لتقد مضاجع
السودانيين مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غرب
دارفور شهدت واحده من اسوا الاحداث حيث
اخذت الازمه بعدا قبليا وسجلت الامم
المتحده مخاوف جديه من وقوع جرائم ضد
الانسانيه في الجنينه في خضم ذلك كله بدات
محاولات اقليميه ودوليه للتوسط بين طرفي
الازمه حاولت منظمه ايجاد انجاز ارضيه
مشتركه لوقف القتال تعثرت المحاولات ولم
تنجح الا بهدنه انسانيه مؤ
بدوره قدم الاتحاد الافريقي مبادره تستند
الى تبني ما تقدمت به ايجاد ليبني خريطه
طريق لم يكتب لها النجاح ايضا
وقدمت السعوديه والولايات المتحده مبادره
والتقى ممثلون عن الطرفين في مباحثات غير
مباشره بمدينه جده
وانشات الدولتان الراعيتان اليه مراقبه لم
تفلح بدورها في ارساء وقف دائم للقتال
وكما في كل منطقه حرب وتوتر يدفع المدنيون
الثمن الاعلى تغيب الارقام الرسميه لاعداد
الضحايا لكن الامم المتحده تقدر عدد
القتلى باكثر من ثلاثه الاف غالبيتهم من
المدنيين
واكثر من سته ملايين سوداني باتوا على شفا
المجاعه وقرابه اربعه ملايين شخص اضطروا
الى ترك منازلهم ولجا منهم قرابه مليون
الى دول الجوار وتقول مفوضيه شؤون
اللاجئين ان اكثر من 14 مليون طفل بحاجه
الى مساعدات انسانيه
[موسيقى]
ومعنا من ادي سببا يوسف عزه المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات الدعم السريع في
السودان اهلا وسهلا بك ما موقفكم مما قاله
السيد مالك عقار بخصوص الدعم السريع سواء
انه لا مكان لجيشين في دوله واحده او
تعداده لما قال انه انتهاكات وجرائم
ارتكبتها قوات الدعم السريع
اولا انا يعني اسمع او رايت مالك عقار كذا
مره في الخرطوم وفي اطار الاتفاق الايطالي
يعرف انه كان يمثل الحركه الشعبيه
قطاعا الى الازرق ضمن الموقعين على اتفاق
وهو وقع الاتفاق على طارد من القوه الموقع
على اتفاق الايطالي لكن اليوم رايت قوه
الاتفاق الايطاليه اجتمعت هنا في اديس ابا
ولم يكن هو منهم وليس طرفا في كل العمليات
واسمع عوره واقرا انه جزء من من الجيش او
يعمل لصالح البرهان او لصالح الجيش في
مناصب لا اعرفها ما زالت قائمه ام لا انا
لا اعرف من هو مالك حقار او من يمثل او هل
هو منظمه مجتمع مدني يرفع تقارير انتهاكات
هو يتحدث بمن اسم من يتحدث مالك عقار لا
ادري ولذلك ليس لدي تعليق على ما يقوله
مالك عقار ولا اعرف اي من اي موقع يتحدث
بغض النظر نعم يعني بغض النظر عن تقييمك
لشخص مالك عقار ما قاله كلام يستدعي توضيح
الرجل له منصب وقال كلاما يعني الدعم
السريعا مما يستوجب موقفا للرد عليه بغض
النظر عن موقفكم مما هو يعني
لا انا اتحدث عن مالك عقار قبل الحرب قبل
15 ابريل اعرف مالك عقار كحركه شعبيه
كرئيس لحركه شعبيه مواقعه الاتفاق
الايطالي اعرف ذلك الموقف لكن لا اجد
يتحدث مثله الان مثل اي ناشط يعني يكتب
ويقول وسائل الاعلام مليئه بهذه الاشياء
وبهذه الادانات لكن لا اعرف ان اي منصب
تتحدث او اين هذا المنصب او لا نحن في
القصر الجمهوري نحن موجودين في الخرطوم
نحن موجودين في مركز السلطه وراين موقع
مالك عقار ومن يمثل
هو نائب رئيس مجلس مالك عقار هو نائب رئيس
مجلس السياده المبادره التي تحدث عنها
تحدث عنها باسم الحكومه وانت هنا لا
تجيبني على مقاله هو اتهم قوات الدعم
السريع بانه ارتكبت جرائم
وانتهاكات من اغتصاب وتهجير وغيرها وقال
بانه لا مكان لجيشين في في بلد واحد يعني
يسعدنا ان نسمع ردكم على هذه النقاط يعني
لا تبقى في نقطه من هو ملك عقار هذا ربما
مهم في سياق نقاش اخر يعني لا
لا لا هذا مهم لانه انت تحدث عن مجلس
سياده اين مجلس السياده الان هنا يوجد
الهادي الدكتور الهادي الان في اديس هو
عضو مجلس سياده الطائر حجر عضو مجلس
السياده برهان له اربع شهور في في بدروم
ورئيس مجلس السياده سابقا حمايه لم يعد
جزاء
مؤسسات سلطه قائمه هذا وضع لا ادري اين
مجلس السياده نفسه اين مكتب برهان الان
يجلس عليه وكيل عريف من الدعم السريع في
كرسي برهان هذا هو الوضع فاين مجلس
السياده واين السلطه الغائمه هل في
السودان هنالك سلطه غائمه هذا سؤال ستجاوب
انا اطرح عليك اسئله وانت ترفض الاجابه
عنها وتطرح اسئله يعني هذا لن يقودنا الى
شيء انا اطرح اسئله
ولم تجبني على مقاله
يا اخي انا مالك عقار كشخص لا اعرفه
التقيته مرتين في حياتي ولا اعرفه وليس
صديقي ولا تربطني به مشاكل الشخصيه ولا
ولا يهمني مالك عقار انا اتحدث عن الواقع
في السودان اليوم هل هنالك سلطه قائمه هل
هنالك مجلس زياده يجتمع متى اخر مره اجتمع
مجلس السياده ليخرج راي يعني هذه قضاية
الميديا
واضح واضح مع الواقع الذي اراه بعيني
واعرفه نعم واضح تماما سيد عزه واضح تماما
سيد عزت انك لا تريد ان تجيب علامه من
اسئله واضح تماما دعنا ننتقل الى ليس لا
اريد انا
انا ابدا
ان اجيبك على اشخاص يا سيد عزت انا اسال
اذا مالك
يمصي الغرير
عن جوجل انسان يمكننا ان ارد عليه كناشط
او كناشه
اين مجلس السياده متى متى اذا
متى اجتمع اخر
تاريخ اجتمع مجلس السياده وقرر اذا وصلنا
مجلس السياده واين اذا اخذنا بهذا المنطق
ساقول لك هل يوجد اخذنا بهذا المنطق يجب
ان تكون معلومه يا سيد عزت اذا اخذنا بهذا
المنطق
ووصلنا بالاسئله
ومن هي قوات الدعم السريع واين السودان
واين الجيش وسنستمر في طرح هذه الاسئله
بشكل صف سطائي انا
نعم هذا يتطلب الرجل
الاسئله هذه الاسئله نفسها مهمه هذه
الاسئله مهمه هذه الاسئله مهمه لشكل
السلطه في السودان لشكل الجيوش في السودان
للحل التعزيز الذي يحاول سرقته مالك عقار
والتحديث به هذا هذه الاسئله التي نريد
يا سيدي يا سيدي ما هو مستقبل الجيش ما هو
مستقبل السلطه السودان لم دعوا هنالك
السلطه قائمه في السودان يا اخي هذه حقيقه
لا توجد اي مؤسسات وزارات الخارجيه كل
الوزارات
ماذا نفعل اذن في هذه الحاله اذا في هذه
اذا في هذه الحاله في هذه الحاله
نسلم البلد للفوضى بالكامل هناك مبادره
هناك مبادره الرجل بغض النظر عن رايه عن
رايك فيه الرجل الرجل اسمح لي فقط انهي
سؤال الرجل ليس لدي راي في شخص يا اخي
لن تظهره الرجل
له منصب سياسي
وقدم مبادره للحوار وخارطه الطريق
بهذا المنصب انا اعترف بما وقعنا عليه يوم
خمسه ابريل اسمه الاتفاق الايطالي ومالك
عقار كان جزء منه وحركته جزء من هذا
الاتفاق وهذا الاتفاق يجب ان يقود الى
سلطه مدنيه ديموقراطيه وخروج المؤسسه
العسكريه من الحكم هذا هذا ما اعرفه اخر
مره عن مالك عجاره ام ممثله في اللجنه
الاشرافيه الذي كنت التلقيه باستمرار يمثل
لحركه الحركه الشعبيه قطاع النيل الازرق
ورئيسها مالك عقار هذا معرفه عن مالك عقار
في السابق اما بعد 15 ابريل لا اعرف ماذا
اي سلطه من هو مالك عقار يتحدث باسم من
انا
لست عن هذه المساله معانيه بالاجابه
مستقبل السودان مستقبل السياسي
في مبادره طرحت وانت لا تريد ان تتحدث عن
مبادره انا اطرح اسئله وانت تطرح اسئله
على كل شكرا لك سيد يوسف
نحن ملتزمين نحن ملتزمين بمبادره نحن
ملتزمين بمنبره جده وحتى الان وفدنا موجود
في منبر جده بالمبادره الامريكيه السعوديه
وندعو لتوحيد كافه المبادرات نحن هنا في
اديس ابا نلتقي الاتحاد الافريقي نلتقي
لايجاد نحاول توحيد كل المبادرات وهذا
طرحنا كل المبادرات قبل المبادلات نفسها
لابد ان يتوحد السودانيين على الحل الشامل
هذه هي المساله شكرا لك شكرا لك سيد
الهندي عز الدين
عفوا السيد يوسف عزه شكرا جزيلا لك كنت
معنا من ادي سببا الان ينضم الينا الان
السيد هندي عز الدين من الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ينضم الينا من القاهره اسالك على
الاقل
ان نذكر باجابات منك على الاقل فيما يتعلق
بهذه المبادره التي طرحها السيد النائب
رئيس مجلس السياده عن خريطه الطريق وحوار
كيف يمكن ان يجري التفاعل معها
لانه لا يعرف مالك عقارب مالك عقار وهو
نائب رئيس مجلس سياده قبل 15 ابريل كان
عضو مجلس السياده بيسلو مسلحه نفسه
الوثيقه الدستوريه والدستور الفتره
الانتقاليه لا تتحدث عن انه نائب اول
لرئيس مجلس السياده هو عضو للصياده مثله
مثل مالك عقار هذه الخريطه الطريق التي
طرحها النائب رئيس مجلس السياده مالك عقار
انا اعتقد انها اخر ما يمكن التوصل اليه
اخر ما يمكن ان تقدمه الحكمه السودانيه
اخر ما يمكن ان تقدمه القوى السياسيه وهو
قائد احد الفصائل السياسيه الموقعه على
الاتفاق جبة تحدث عن الفصل بين القوات
بمعنى خروج قوات الدعم السريعه الميليشيا
من الاحياء السكنيه من المناطق المدنيه من
المستشفيات من المدارس من المساجد
كما ينز على ذلك اتفاق جده وقال الان
مستشار قال انه ملتزمون باتفاق جده اذا
اتفاق جده في 21 مايو يقول بخروج الدعم
السريع من بيوت المواطنين يقول بازاله
الارتكازات التي تعطل حركه المواطنين يقول
بالتوقف عن النهب والسلب فتح ممرات
انسانيه اذا اذهب ونفذ اتفاق جده الان
الملك عقار طرح انه خروج هذه القوات
تجميعه في معسكرات خارج المناطق السكنيه
ثم قبلها تكوين حكومه الطوارئ ثم الذهاب
الى مؤتمر دستوري سياسي يجمع كل القوى
السياسيه انا افتكر على قياده الدعم
السريع ان كانت لها قياده ان كان حمايه
حيا ما زال حيا ان كان عبد الرحيم دقله
يستطيع ان يفهم ويتفاهم ويستوعب ما يجري
الان في السودان ان العمليه العسكريه
الكبيره التي قاموا عليها للاست
ما هم تم الاتفاق في جده وقبل جده كانت
هنالك هدى يعني الجيشين
وقعوا على اتفاقيات هدى انحداشر هدنه كان
هنالك وقف في اطلاق نار محدود ولكن في
النهايه اذا تم الالتزام بما تم الاتفاق
عليه والتوقيع عليه في جده في 21 مايو
خروج الدعم السريع من مناطق السكنيه خروج
من الاحياء عدم تعويق حركه المواطنين فتح
الممرات الانسانيه هذا يعني التزام الجيش
بوقف اطلاق النار وبالتالي الدعم السريعه
الان يبحث عن حل لانه متورط الان في عمليه
عسكريه لم يستطيع تحقيق اي من اهدافها
شكرا جزيلا لك الهندي عز الدين الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
الى ليبيا حيث قالت مصادر الجزيره ان جهاز
الردع التابع للمجلس الرئاسي الليبي سلم
امر اللواء 444 محمود حمزه الى قوه محايده
خارج مطار الدولي وذلك بعد اجتماع عقده
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
الدبيبه مع عدد من القاده العسكريين وكانت
المواجهات بين جهاز الردع واللواء 444 ادت
الى مقتل اربعه اشخاص في طرابلس وافاد
مراسل الجزيره بان الدبيبه طالبه وزيره
داخليته ورئيس الاركان بالتدخل لفض
الاشتباكات في مناطق جنوبيه العاصمه
معنى الان من تونس السفير ريتشارد نولاند
المبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى ليبيا اهلا
وسهلا بك ما موقفكم مما جرى اليوم في
طرابلس
اولا شكرا جزيلا للاستضافه
طبعا نحن نتابع منذ ليله امس اتطورات بقلق
بالغ حول اصدقائنا الليبيين نحن نفهم بان
محمود حمزه منذ مسال والذي اعتقاله اشعل
نار هذا القتال قد تم اطلاق سراحه وان
هناك وقفا لاطلاق النار
وبناء على مفاوضات جرت بين قيادات عسكريه
ورؤوس الدوله وفي نفس الوقت نحن نستمر
بمراقبه مجريات الامور على الارض لنتاكد
من وقت القتال نحن ومع شركائنا الدوليين
مع الامم المتحده ندعو جميع الاطراف
المتقاتله الى الكف عن زعزعه
الاستقرار وان يخوضوا في حوار
ليبيا حقق التقدما كبيرا الماضيه نحو
تحويل
توحيد البلاد وبدات
الاجواء الانتخابات وليس من مصلحه احد ان
يعيق هذا التقدم المتحده تنميه الاستمرار
في دعمها القاده الليبيين وهم ينخرطون مع
بعضنا البعض ومع عبد الله باتيليا الخاص
الامين العام للمتحده لتوحيد البلاد
واجراء انتخابات ناجحه عبد الله بديل نفسه
كان حذر منذ اشهر من تداعيات
ادامه هذا الوضع الحالي في ليبيا على
الاستقرار وعلى التسويه برايك لماذا لم
تتحرك واشنطن والمجتمع الدولي بقوه كافيه
للدفع باتجاه الانتخابات والتسويه
السياسيه
اعتقد اننا كنا واضحين تماما في دعمنا
للمبعوث الخاصه المتحده ويحاول تسيير
الحوار الذي هم بحاجه الى اجرائه وان
يجتمع القاده الاساسيون ويتفقون على خارطه
الطريق لها مصداقيته هذا امر لا يمكن
للوقت المتحده ان تفرضه وتمليه لكنه شيء
ندعمه بقوه في كل
انخراطاتنا مع القاده الليبيين وقد كان
هناك حقيقه تقدم احرز في الاشهر الماضيه
لا نريد للعنف ان يعيد مثل هذا التقدم الى
الوراء يعني هذا التقدم كيف يمكن ان يبنى
عليه في الفتره المقبله
نعطيكم مثالا اولهم ان التقدم الذي حصل في
المسار الامني فيما يسمى بخمسه زائدا خمسه
اللجنه العسكريه حيث يلتقي كبار القاده
العسكريين سويه ويعمل سويه لتمهيد الاجواء
لتحقيق هيكليه عسكريه موحده وقوه عسكريه
موحده يمكن ان تذهب الى السيطره على
الحدود الجنوبيه لليبيا مع السودان
وغيرها من الدول الجوار وكانت هناك
مناقشات جاده حقيقه حول هذه القضيه والمثل
الاخر هو الجهود
المبذوله
لكي يكون هناك رقابه شفافه على عائدات
النفط الليبيه التي لا يستهانوا بها
بتاسيس اللجنه ماليه عليا وقد كانت هناك
لقاءات ايجابيه للتوصل الاتفاقيات حول
كيفيه توزيع الثروات بين الشرق والغرب وان
تذهب الاموال الى حيث قد اتفقوا على
ذهابها اليه مع ذلك سعد السفير هل تعتقدون
بان انصراف المجتمع الدولي لموضوع الحرب
في اوكرانيا او ما يحصل الان في السودان
منذ اشهر
صرف الانظار الى حد ما على ضروره السعي
نحو الحل في ليبيا
لا ارى ذلك نحن ندرك ان ليبيا جزء من
الاقليم والليبيون انفسهم يريدون لبلادهم
ان لا ينجرا الا ازمات اقليميه او ان
يساهم في مفاقمه الازمات الاقليميه لهذا
السبب نرى هناك حاجه ماسه لجميع القاده
على المستوى الامني والاقتصادي وفي خاتمه
المطافه المستوى السياسي لتوحيد البلاد
ووضع هيكليات من شانه ان تعزز سياده ليبيا
في اقليم صعب للغايه والوتر المتحده سوف
تستمر في دعمها لهذه الجهود هل لديكم اي
تخوفات سيد نورلاند من ان ما جرى البارحه
واليوم في طرابلس قد يتطور الى ما هو اخطر
في الفتره المقبله
اعتقد ان هذا هو مبعث القلق دائما كلما
اندلع العنف راينا ذلك في اغسطس
الماضي من العام الماضي المهم هو ان يتم
احتواء العنف فورا وان يتصرف كل الاطراف
بهذه الطريق هناك مظالم مشروعه لدى اطراف
مختلفه لكن يمكن حله عن طريق الحوار ونحن
ندعم جهود ذلك الحوار ونسمن دوره كثير من
القاده الليبيين مساهمتهم في هذا الحوار
والصوره الاكبر طبعا تبقى متمثله بوجود
المبعوث الخاص بالمتحده لتسهيل وتسهيل
الحوار بينهم وسوف نستمر بدعمه هو ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك سفينه المبعوث الامريكي
الخاص الى ليبيا كنت معنا من تونس
[موسيقى]
الى ازمه النيجر واجواء ترقب بعد اعلان
اكواس ان رؤساء اركان الجيوش المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا سوف يجتمعون
في اكرم الخميس
جدى ذلك جدد ذلك احتماليه التدخل العسكري
لكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه قال اليوم
انه لا تزال هناك فرصه للدبلوماسيه لاعاده
الامور الى نصابها في النيجر وفي اتصال
هاتفي اكد رئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
لرئيس مالي اهميه ايجاد حل سلمي للوضع في
النيجر
انقسام على انقلاب عسكري افريقيا من قمه
طارئه الى اخرى ومن اجتماع الى اخر
يستعصي عليها انتزاع اجماع لتعليق عضويه
النيجر في الاتحاد الافريقي وموافقه جميع
دول اكواس على التدخل العسكري لاعاده
الرئيس بازون والنظام الدستوري تبدو
مستحيله
يوصل العسكر حكمهم المدان والمرفوضه من
بعض الدول الاقليميه الغربيه اكثر في
اصدار قرارات بالجمله وبشكل شبهي خارجيا
لم تتوقف بياناته وتصريحات الشرج التي
وصفت اعلان العسكر محاكمه الرئيس المحتجز
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى بالخطوه الاستفزازيه
خلال جوله لغرب افريقيا جددت وزيره
التعاون الاقتصادي والتنميه الالمانيه
سيفينيا شوتس الدعوه الى الافراج الفوري
عن بازو وقالت ان الانقلاب العسكري في
النيجر يمثل انتكاسه ستفاقم التنميه
المعقده في البلاد وفي منطقه الساحل اكثر
مما هي عليه عن النيجر والخيار السلمي ليس
دونه لحل الازمه تحدث خلال اتصال هاتفي
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين والحاكم
العسكري في مالي اسانيوغويتا عسكر مالي
وبوركينا فاسو اعلن سابقا ان اي تدخل
عسكري في النيجر بمنزله اعلان حرب عليهما
ورد في بيان الكرملين ان الطرفين اكد على
وجه الخصوص اهميه التسويه الوضع في النيجر
من خلال الطرق السياسيه والدبلوماسيه
السلميه فقط منذ السادس والعشرين من يوليو
الماضي لم يغير اي قرار او اعلان او وعيد
من الافارقه في اديس ابا او ابوجا من خطه
عسكر النيجر قاده جيوش ايكواس في اجتماعهم
المنتظر باكرر الخميس والجمعه المقبلين
ماذا هم فاعلون تاجيل اجتماعهم الذي كان
مقررا السبت الماضي مؤشر على ان قرار
العمل العسكري المرغوبه فيه بشده من البعض
والمرفوضه من اطراف اخرى لن يكون امرا
يسيرا انقلاب النيجر وضع الجميع في ورطه
وامام خيارات كلها بين الصعب والاصعب
المساله تتعدى حدود تعليق نظام دستوري
واحتجاز رئيس المنتخب في بلد فقير رغم
ثرواته المعدنيه انها معركه اخرى في حرب
المصالح والنفوذ بين القوى الكبرى على ارض
النيجر
ومعنى من ذكاء ابراهيم يحيى ابراهيم وحلل
شؤون الساحل الفريقين في مجموعه الازمات
الدوليه اهلا وسهلا بك سيد ابراهيم هذه
المراوحه بين الحل الدبلوماسي والخيار
العسكري الى متى ستتواصل
للاسف صوت المذيع صوت الضيف لا يصلنا
اذا اعيد السؤال سالت السيد ابراهيم يحيى
ابراهيم عن هذه المراوحه بين الحل
الدبلوماسي والخيار العسكري الى متى
ستستمر
[موسيقى]
اشرتم اليه الان هم سيعقدوا جلسه اخرى يوم
الخميس لمواصله
[موسيقى]
المشاوره والحديث حول التدخل العسكري لكن
في نفس الوقت هم يقولون بانهم يفضلون الحل
الدبلوماسي والسياسي لكن كما يقول احدهم
هذا حل الدبلوماسي هي مفاوضات مع مسدس على
الطاوله يعني انهم يحاولوا اجبار الحكومه
العسكريه لكي تاخذوا دماغهم يريدون ومن اي
اخرى نحن شاهدنا موقف تحدي من من
رؤساء العسكر كما
[موسيقى]
جاء في البدايه هو اول شيء رفضوا مقابله
الوسطاء التي الذي ارسلوه ارسلوه رؤساء
الاخوه وربما هذا ربما هذا ربما يعني
معذره سيد ابراهيم ربما هذا هو المشكل
الخيار الدبلوماسي لا يتقدم والخيار
العسكري يبتعد وهذا الامر هو في النهايه
في مصلحه قاده الانقلاب
لا صحيح هم انهم
في موقفهم حاليا
الموقف والوقت اللي بدا يعني يزول هذا
يربحكم لكن يعني اظن انه من الصعب ان ان
نقوم ان نقول بان الحل العسكري خلاص يعني
تم الغائه وان الموقف الدبلوماسي الذي
سيجعل
الحكومه العسكريه تبقى على الحكم هو
الوحيد الذي تبقى انا اظن ان هذا سيكون
خطا لو الحكومه العسكريه هي تظن بان رؤساء
الاقوى خلاص الغوا موقف الموقف العسكري
كما قلنا يعني
بعد الدول اصلا بدات تجمع
عركانها يعني
قوتها في مكان مثلا السنغال
وكوت ديفوار يعني في هذه الدولتين بالاخص
يعني القوات بدات تتجمع ولكن الخيار
العسكري الان الكل يحاول ان يبعد شبحه
وهناك حديث عن معارضه كبيره للخيار
العسكري حتى في شمال النيجر في شمال
نيجيري عفوا وبالتالي اصبحت نيجيريا في حد
ذاتها وهي التي تقود الاكواس في وضع محرج
صحيح فيه ضغوطات كثيره يعني من قبل
من الداخل من داخل الدول الاقوى بما فيها
نيجيريا وبما فيها بنين وبما فيها في كل
الدول فيه اصوات تقوم وتحذر من عواقب
الوخيمه التي يمكن تنتج من
التدخل العسكري كما نحن شاهدنا ايضا يعني
الدول الاخرى
المواقف الدول الكبيره مثل الولايات
المتحده كما اشرتم في البدايه الولايات
المتحده كانت تدعم الموقف
شكرا لك ابراهيم يحيى ابراهيم من ذكر شكرا
جزيلا لك
هذا ويواصل المؤيدون للمجلس العسكري في
النيجر تظاهراتهم للمطالبه بخروج القوات
الفرنسيه من بلادهم وقد الغى قاده
الانقلاب باتفاقيات التعاون الامني
والدفاعي مع باريس المستعمر السابق
لبلادهم وترفض فرنسا الاعتراف بالمجلس
العسكري وتدعم الخطوات التي اتخذتها
مجموعه بلدان غرب افريقيا لاعاده الرئيس
محمد بازون الى السلطه
تلك المسيرات التي تدعو لخروج القوات
الفرنسيه من النيجر
اصبحت امرا شبه يومي في شوارع نيامه
شعارات يتبناها كثير من قاده الجيش
سندها الشعبي تتصدره عده جمعيات مدنيه
لعبت دورا في تحريك الشارع منذ عده سنوات
فرنسا في النيجر لزعزعه الاستقرار في
بلدان الساحل وخارج منطقه الساحل سياسه
فرنسا ايضا تقوم على زعزعه دول الجوار منذ
تاسيس حركتنا كنا ضد وجود القوات العسكريه
الفرنسيه
لفرنسي في السابقه في ستينيات وسبعينيات
القرن الماضي الى ان قرر نظام الحكم
العسكري انذاك الغاء الاتفاقيات الامنيه
والدفاعيه معها في منتصف السبعينيات
غادرت بعدها القوات الفرنسيه النيجر لتعود
تلك القوات مجددا الى النيجر في عام 2011
حيث انشات فرنسا قاعده عسكريه لها في
منطقه بولما اقصى شمال النيجر قرب الحدود
مع ليبيا وشات لكن انشطتها الرئيسيه
تتركزت في قاعدتها العسكريه في العاصمه
نياميه والتي تؤوي جنودها واعتادها ومنها
تدير باريس قواتها العسكريه في المنطقه
وتساعدها قوات اوروبيه من المانيا
وايطاليا بعد سحب قواتها من مالي وبوركينا
فاسو المجاورتين للنيجر
ترفض فرنسا لاعتراف بالمجلس العسكري كسلطه
شرعيه في النيجر كما ترفض قراراته بالغاء
الاتفاقيات الدفاعيه معها وسحب قواتها كما
تدعم عوده الرئيس محمد بازوم الى السلطه
انها حرب مصالح بالنسبه لفرنسا بنفس
الطريقه التي تسعى بها باريس الى اعاده
الرئيس بازوم الى السلطه فانها تعمل ايضا
على الحفاظ على مصالحه باختصار عوده
الرئيس تعني حفظ مصالح فرنسا في النيجر
ومنذ اندلاع الازمه في النيجر اصبح هذا
المكان مقصدا للكثيرين من سكان العاصمه
ومطلبهم الوحيد خروج فرنسا من النيجر هذه
هي القاعده الفرنسيه في نيامه
هنا يمكث نحو
1500 جندي فرنسي وامامها يتظاهر الكثير من
السكان مطالبين برحيل هذه القوات
والتوسع في التعاون الامني مع بلدان اخرى
يرون انها اكثر نفعا لبلادهم في حربها ضد
الجماعات المسلحه
فضل عبد الرزاق الجزيره
ومعلم البريزه السيده ليزلي مديره معهد
اليقظه لدراسه العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه والخبيره في الشان
الافريقيه اهلا وسهلا بك
هل اقتربت ساعه رحيل القوات الفرنسيه من
النيجر الان
سؤال وجيه بالفعل
عاده
اذا ما اردتم يمكننا ان نشير الى
الاتفاقيات التي الغيت هذه الاتفاقيات
المتعدده
وايضا نتحدث عن مهله سته اشهر او سنه ولكن
بالنسبه الى
الانسحاب يجب ان يتم في غضون سته اشهر
بحسب
العسكريين بالنسبه الي هذه المهله قصيره
للغايه لانكم كما تتذكرون في مالي تطلب
الامر اشهر طويله لكي تغادر القوات
الفرنسيه مالي بسبب الجوانب اللوجستيه اذا
الفرنسيون لا يعترفون كما اشرتم في
تقريركم
بالسلطه النيجيريه الحاليه وبالتالي تبقى
الفرنسيه الوضع في غايه التعقيد وغايه
الصعوبه وغايه التوتر هل سوف تغادر القوات
الفرنسيه بشكل مبكر هل تتوقع فرنسا ان
المجلس العسكري سوف يغادر السلطه وسوف
يعود الرئيس بزوم الى سته الرئاسه هذه
اسئله مفتوحه وصعبه على اي حال وبغض النظر
عن نتيجه هذا النزاع يبدو ان فرنسا يتعين
عليها ان تغادر في من تلك المنطقه بالنظر
الى التوتر في المنطقه هل معنى ذلك بان
القوات الفرنسيه لن تبقى الا اذا عاد
بازون وبالتالي فالمساله
هكذا بهذا الشكل
لم يعد السيد بزوم الى ارياس انا لا ارى
كيف للقوات الفرنسيه ان تبقى في البلاد
هذا امرا في غايه الصعوبه الان
الامريكيون اذا ما فتحوا قنوات اتصال مع
العسكريين بالاضافه الى المبادرات التي
اتخذت تجاه المسؤولين الكبار في المجلس
العسكري حتى اللحظه الراهنه فرنسا ليس
لديها اي قنوات للاتصال مع القاده
العسكريين في النيجر بذلك لا ارى افق هذه
المفاوضات التي يمكن ان تؤدي الى بقاء
القوات الفرنسيه في حال لم يعد السيد
بازوم الى سده الرئاسه ومع مرور الوقت يجب
ان نتذكر ان الامر يصبح اصعب لكي يعود
السيد بازوم الى الرئاسه لذلك نحن في مازق
وفي وضع صعب بالنسبه الى النيجر ومنطقيا
اذا ما اردنا ان نحذف بشكل منطقي نرى ان
فرنسا والقوات الفرنسيه سوف يتعين عليها
ان تغادر النيجر فكرت بالامر بطرق متعدده
ولم اجد الى هذه الاجابه شكرا جزيلا لك
السيده لجلي فنان من باريس
[موسيقى]
الان الى حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث صعدت
القوات الروسيه هجماتها على غرب اوكرانيا
على نحو لافت مؤكده انها استهدفت مواقع
تصنيعا عسكري اوكرانيه في المقابل تتحدث
كيم عن سقوط خمسه مدنيين في الضربات التي
طالت 13 مقاطعه في انحاء البلاد تطورات
تزامنت مع تصريحات للطرفين بشان استخدام
الصواريخ ومصدرها
جبهه ريمان في مقاطعه دانيت لطالما شكلت
محور تركيز لدى طرفي الحرب منذ شهور
لموقعها الاستراتيجي تعلن الدفاع الروسيا
استهدافها مواقع للجيش الاوكراني فيما
يعرف بمنطقه حزام الغابات ولما نقطه
انطلاق رئيسيه من الشمال في خرسون فيما
يبدو محاوله لمنع تقدم اوكراني تكشف قوات
دينيبرو في الجيش الروسي قصفها بالمدفعيه
والمسيرات مواقع لقوات المدفعيه
الاوكرانيه واحبطها محوله اوكرانيه لنقل
جنود بقوارب سريعه وفي مقاطعه بارياس داخل
روسيا تعلن سلطاتها اصابه شخص جراء محاوله
تسادل ما سمتها مجموعه تخريبيه اوكرانيه
لاراضي المقاطعه بمقابل استراتيجيه ارباك
اوكرانيه واضح شرقا تضرب روسيا غربا في
ليبيفيف القريبه من الحدود البولنديه هجوم
صاروخي شملها وثلاث عشره منطقه اخرى قالت
قياده القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه ان قوت
اسقطت عددا كبيرا من الصواريخ وبمقاطعه
فولين دوما في غرب اوكرانيا قصف روسي
استهدف مصنعا لقطع غيار السيارات وفق رئيس
بلديه مدينه لوتسك التابعه للمقاطعه
بالمجمل تتحدث الدفاع الروسيه عن تنفيذ
هجمات مركزه باسلحه بعيده المدى وعاليه
الدقه من الجو والبحر تقول انها استهدفت
مؤسسات رئيسيه في الصناعه العسكريه
الاوكرانيه وتشير تحديدا الى اصابه مركز
قياده الحرب الالكترونيه وانظمه الدفاع
الجوي للقوات الاوكرانيه فكره
المتحدث باسم قياده القوه الجويه
الاوكرانيه اشار الى توجيه الطائره
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه صواريخها من نوع كي
اتش 22 الى مدينه كرامه مما صعد اسقاط
بعضها كما كان لافتان اشارته الى ان اطلاق
صواريخ روسيه من بحر قزوين اعقب ذلك معركه
الصواريخ دفعت مدير مكتب الرئيس الاوكراني
عن استخدام روسيا صواريخ من نوع 101
ويحتوي الواحد منها على نحو 30 قطعه
مستورده ما يطرح تساؤلات بشان مصادر هذه
القطع بالمقابل تتحدث الدفاع الروسيه عن
اعتراض الصواريخ كروس بعيده المدى
الفرنسيه السنه من طراز
اورجان وعن اسقاط 25 مسيره تلك تطورات
الشرق والغرب ولا تبتعد الجبهه الجنوبيه
عما يحدث هناك باعلان القياده العسكريه في
اوديسا اسقاط خمسه عشره مسيره وثمانيه
صواريخ متهمه موسكو بالسعي لتدمير البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه وذاك عنوان
معركه اخرى على ضفاف البحر الاسود
في الاثناء قال رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني
دينيست شبيهه لانه يعتزم بناء تحصينات
جديده وبنيه تحتيه عسكريه في المناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه المتاخمه لروسيا
وبيلاروسيا بتكلفه تقارب خمسه خمسه
وثلاثين مليون دولار
القصف الروسي الذي استهدف لفيف اليوم يعني
ان الصواريخ الروسيه سقطت بالقرب من
الحدود الاوكرانيه مع بولندا في خطوه من
شانها ان تثير مخاوف وارسو وقد تزامن هذا
مع احتفال بولندا اليوم بيوم الجيش وذكرى
معركه وارسو عام 1920 التي يقول المؤرخون
البولنديون انها اوقفت حينها زحف الشيوعيه
باتجاه اوروبا الغربيه
وتلقي الحرب في اوكرانيا بظلالها على
بولندا المجاوره التي تعد خط امداد
للاسلحه الغربيه التي تصل الى كييف وقد
اقيم عرض عسكري في العاصمه وارسو هو
الاكبر منذ الحرب البارده كشفت فيه بولندا
عن احدث الاسلحه التي اقتنتها مؤخرا
[موسيقى]
في واشنطن قالت نائبه المتحدثه باسم البيت
الابيض اوليفيا دالتون ان البيت الابيض لن
يعلق على لائحه الاتهام الصادره بحق
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب في
جورجيا وندد ترامب من جهته بالاتهامات
الموجهه اليه بمحاوله قلب نتائج
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في ولايه جورجيا وقال
ان لائحه الاتهام الصادره بحقه زائفه
وملفقه معتبرا ان هدف الاجراء والنيل من
حملته لتمثيل الحزب الجمهوري في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2004
ولكن ما هو قانون ريكو الذي قد يكون مفتاح
ادانه للرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب في ولايه جورجيا
[موسيقى]
وضع قانون المنظمات الفاسده والممارسه
للابتزاز المعروف اختصارا بقانون ريكو عام
1970 لمكافحه الجرائم المنظمه والعصابات
استخدم لاحقا لاسيما في
8900 القرن الماضي لملاحقه زعماء المافيا
وتفكيك عصاباتهم
يعاقب القانون مرتكبه جرائم الامتفاع غير
المشروع او حتى من يحاول ارتكابها لتحقيق
مصلحه منظمه اجراميه ويشمل نحو 40 جريمه
تراوح بين الجنح البسيطه والجنايات
الخطيره في حين تتفاوت عقوبه الادانه تحت
ظل القانون بين خمس سنوات وعشرين سنه وقد
جرى تعديل القانون في ولايه جورجيا ليشمل
المشاركين في الجرائم تخدم هدفا واحدا
وليس بالضروره منظمه اجراميه
لكن كيف يمكن ان يؤثر قانون ريكو في
محاكمه ترامب يتيح قانون ريكو ادانه ترامب
دون الحاجه الى اثبات انه اعطى الاوامر
لقلب نتيجه الانتخابات اذ يكفي فقط انه
تامر مع المتهمين الاخرين لتحقيق ذلك بحسب
الخبراء فان قانون ريكو يحفز المتهمين
الذين لم يؤدوا دورا كبيرا في محاوله قلب
نتيجه الانتخابات والمهددين بفتره سجن
طويله على عقد صفقه على الادعاء لتخفيض
عقوبتهم مقابل معلومات تدين ترامب ومع
وجود 18 متهما ذوي مسؤوليات متفاوته فان
اللجوء اي منهم لهذه الخطوه يبقى امرا
واردا في حال ادانه ترامب فقد يحكم عليه
بالسجن لمده طويله لا تقل عن خمس سنوات ما
يعني انهاء مسيرته السياسيه وطموحه
بالعوده الى البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
الماء مقابل الكهرباء انها صيغه مبادره
اقليميه روج لها في اجتماع عقد الاثنين في
ابوظبي وضم مسؤولين من الاردن والامارات
واسرائيل بالاضافه الى ممثلين عن الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه فما حقيقه هذه المبادره
في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني من عام 2021 وقعت
اسرائيل والاردن والامارات اضافه الى
الجانب الامريكي على اعلان مبدئي باتجاه
تنفيذ مبادره الماء من اجل الكهرباء والتي
اطلق عليها اسم مشروع الازدهار يقضي هذا
المشروع المشترك بان تبيع اسرائيل سنويا
للاردن 200 مليون متر مكعب من مياه البحر
المحلات في منشاه ستقام على ساحل البحر
الابيض المتوسط على ان يشتري الاسرائيليون
في المقابل من الاردن الكهرباء الخضراء
التي سيتم تولي في مزرعه شمسيه ستبنيها
دوله الامارات في صحراء الاردن برعايه
امريكيه يذكر ان مبادره الماء مقابل
الكهرباء قبلت بغضب شعبي واسع في الاردن
عندما تم الكشف عن بنودها اواخر عام 2001
والان يتوقع وزير الطاقه والبنيه التحتيه
الاسرائيلي اسرائيل كاتس ان يتم التوقيع
على اتفاقيه بشان تلك المبادره في مؤتمر
المناخ الذي سيعقد في نوفمبر تشرين الثاني
المقبل في دبي
ما زالت هذه المبادره مبادره المياه
بالكهرباء محل بحث
بعمليه تفوضيه تنظر في جدوى مشروعا مشترك
في هذا الشعب لكن الجانب الاسرائيلي يتوقع
ان تتحول المبادره الى منتدى فريدا
للتعاون الرباعي بين تل ابيب وعمان وابو
ظبي وواشنطن لتعزيز مبادرات اضافيه
اسرائيل التي وضعت اهدافا للانتقال الى
الطاقات المتجدده ستستفيد بذلك من مساحات
مفتوحه اكبر بانشاء مزارع شمسيه بينما
المملكه الاردنيه التي تصنف ثانيه افقر
دوله في العالم من حيث وفره المياه ستسعى
لحل واحده من اكثر مشاكلها الحاحا من خلال
ما تعرف بمبادره الازدهار اما دوله
الامارات فستفيدوا في هذا السياق من
الجانبين باعتبارها منفذ المرافق التي
ستكون في هذا المشروع مشروعي تحليه مياه
البحر وانتاج الطاقه الخضراء معنى الان من
براين ستوريوس مدير تحرير مجله الاقتصاد
العالمي والاستاذ في جامعه اهلا وسهلا بك
هل هل هذا المشروع فعلا
مشروع ذو جدوى
من حيث والناحيه النظريه البحته يعني اننا
يمكن ان نعتبر انك بامكانك ان تفعل شيئا
دون اخر اسرائيل مثلا
لديها فائض من المياه بسبب مشاريع التحليه
الاردني يعاني من شحه في الموارد
المائيه لكن الاردن لديه مساحات واسعه من
الاراضي اذا اذا ما جمعنا هذه العناصر
سويه
ونرى كيف ان هناك مشاريع يمكن ان يبنى
فيها اذا مختصر القول انه يمكن ان يقال
انه له جدوى اما كيف من الناحيه النظريه
هو له جدول لكن كيف يمكن تمويله هذه قضيه
اخرى وهل هو صفقه عادله الماء مقابل
الكهرباء من الناحيه الاقتصاديه البحته
نحن لسنا مطلعين على شروطنا الاتفاق طبعا
هذه الصفقه بحثت من قبل مع مصر في السابق
وبعد ذلك
كان ذلك يتعلق بمشروع للفولاذ لكننا لا
ندري حقيقه ما هو كلفه او سعر وحده المال
مقابل وحده الكهرباء لهذا السبب لنا كيف
ستتم المقايضه اذا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه
لا ندري حقيقه ايضا من ناحيه وسائل الطاقه
المتجدده اذا ما بنينا
نعمل لانتاج الطاقه الشمسيه هذا يعني ان
توليد الطاقه الكهربائيه
ستستقلك الفته لكن اسعار
تحليه المياه ستزداد اذا من هذا يجب ان
ننظر كيف نعادل هذه المساله صرت اكثر من
مره باننا لا ندري هل تعتقد بان الموضوع
يحتاج الى شفافيه اكثر لحتى نفهم
يجب ان نعرف ما هو السعر ما هي الكلفه اذا
كنت تقايض النفط مثلا مقابل المواد منتجه
مصنعه مثلا وما هو سعر الوحدات المنتجه
يجب ان تعرف السعر والكلف ثم تعرف ايضا من
سيمول هذه الاستثمار في الطاقه الشمسيه
يتم من قبل وهناك استثمارات كبيره في
تحليه المياه في اسرائيل فهي لديها فائض
اذا هذا من منظور اسرائيل والتوفير المياه
والاردن بحيث الى مزيد من المياه اسرائيل
تحتاج الى المزيد من الكهرباء لاسباب
سياسيه اذا اسرائيل
بسبب زياده حاجات
سكانها وب